c'est marqué ici réfugiés climatiques
numéro 60 2 c'est notre maison forcé à
migrer à cause du dérèglement climatique
les réfugiés de l'environnement sont
désormais bien une réalité mais depuis
quand parle-t-on des réfugiés
climatiques fin des années 70 seuls
quelques scientifiques évoquent le
risque pour les populations
il pourrait y avoir un effet de serre
général réchauffement de 2 ou 3 degrés
de de la température de l'atmosphère est
montée des eaux est donc noyer noyade de
toutes les deux toutes les côtes basses
région de new york est le havre et
marseille et nice et l'on exagère points
est en train de paniquer les populations
là malgré les alertes il faudra attendre
1985 pour voir apparaître le terme de
réfugiés de l'environnement dans un
rapport de l'onu
ils sont définis ainsi ceux qui sont
forcés de quitter leur lieu de vie
temporairement ou de façon permanente à
cause d'une rupture environnementale
d'origine naturelle ou humaine qui a mis
en péril leur existence ou sérieusement
affecter leurs conditions de vie et plus
le temps passe plus les événements
météorologiques se multiplient
on est maintenant sûr au sahel en
afrique le déboisement et le fait
d'avoir voulu gagner de la terre
cultivable sur la savane ont ainsi
modifié le climat local pour transformer
une période de sécheresse normale en une
catastrophe touchant 60 millions de
personnes
en 1992 le sommet de la terre à rio
identifie quatre écosystème fragile et
menacée de destruction
il ya les zones côtières menacées de
subversion bien souvent les zones les
plus peuplées
de la planète vingtaine de maisons ont
déjà dû être évacués si charef paient le
prix fort au réchauffement de la planète
un plan d'urgence a déjà été mis en
place il prévoit l'évacuation de
l'intégralité de la population de 6 marc
f
mais aussi les régions soumises à la
désertification ou à la déforestation
avec le désert qui avance et le lac qui
reculent
un jour ou l'autre il n'y aura plus
assez à manger pour tout le monde des
solutions voit le jour en signant des
accords d'accueil avec des pays voisins
mais aussi en luttant sur place pour
protéger ces îles c'est plante miracle
de la mangrove avec leurs longues
racines elles ont pour effet de retenir
la terre et ralentir l'érosion de la
mangrove face à la mer une plante contre
l'océan ultime tentative de ces indiens
pour endiguer la montée des eaux
malgré les résistances de certaines
populations d'après l'onu aujourd'hui
une personne migre chaque seconde pour
des raisons climatiques
à ce jour aucun régime de protection
légale n'existe pour les réfugiés de
l'environnement
[Musique]